hello my name is eric weisstein
i would like to speak to you today about
the history of mathematics project
this project
is an effort to create a computable and
interactive virtual exhibits of
mathematical artifacts
so just by way of a little bit of
background and some timeline
last year stephen wolfram proposed a
project to develop
virtual interactive collection of math
artifacts that could serve as a
potential precursor
to a real exhibit at the national museum
of mathematics in new york city
this project was generously funded by
overdeck family foundation and over the
last year
uh colleagues and i at wolfram have
investigated written up detailed
histories descriptions and computational
explanations
for a large collection of mathematical
artifacts
the results have been incorporated into
a website
uh history of mathematics.org creative
url
which was created using a custom build
system that was modeled after the one
used by stephen in his physics project
that he showed a little a bit about
yesterday
at his keynote
so um at the get-go i want to give a uh
acknowledgement to the colleagues who
have worked on this together with myself
andrea gerlock
bernat espiguole and sarah kyme williams
at wolfram
and in addition
because of the large scope of this
project not just
geographically but also culturally and
temporally
there's an awful lot of material
spanning a vast domain of human
knowledge
and in order to make sure that we did a
good complete job of dealing with all
those various different pieces of
information
requiring expertise in many different
areas we
over the course of the project built up
a network
of 50 content and domain experts from
all around the world consisting of
academics book authors
experts in all the areas that were
relevant and they have really been
instrumental and extremely helpful
in ensuring
that we
got everything right that we put things
in the correct context and
so it's been extremely helpful
to have that sort of outside
comments while this site was underway as
we move forward of course we hope to
receive much more feedback from a larger
segment of potential readers
experts and non-experts alike to help
move this site further along and make it
better moving forward
so the main part of the talk will be a
show and tell guided tour but before
getting into that the site is actually
live
i just want to talk a little bit about
how it's organized and how it's built
then we'll get into the fun stuff
so as i mentioned the home page for this
project is history of mathematics.org
with dashes on either side of the of
it contains nine virtual exhibit pages
and those contain a total of 74
individual artifacts categorized by
virtual exhibit
in addition there are two
different types of write-ups which we
call learning journeys
and we're currently actively working on
building more of these they provide a
sort of different more education-based
or narrative-based
coverage of
the same material
so virtual exhibits
well in order to move forward with this
project we had to divide things up into
some neat bins into which we could put
our artifacts and the nine topics we
chose for our virtual exhibits
were counting arithmetic algebra as you
can see here pythagorean theorem
geometry primes pi
polyhedra and mathematics education
and by and large this has worked pretty
well there are obviously others that we
have thought of and would like to
include and as this if this project
is successful and continues forward
perhaps we'll have a chance to add them
so on each exhibit page as you'll see
shortly
um each exhibit page contains navigation
to other
exhibits it contains a short description
clickable thumbnails for each of the
artifacts and a clickable timeline
then once you click down to an
individual artifact
you'll see again navigation
lots of metadata such as the date from
which the artifact
originates
descriptions a nice main hero image
additional image thumbnails that you can
view via carousel
um clickable timeline
and lots of additional resources
including sort of the dry desiccated
bibliographic ones but also other
interactive web resources
and additional links to standard sources
such as wikipedia and other definitive
things on the web where you can learn
more
so one of the really exciting things
that we were able to do
as part of this project is to really
take advantage of the wolfram language
to
provide both interactivity and a true
computational explanation of these
artifacts so we can basically
provide a manipula manipulative base
exploration for each artifact that
allows
before getting into some of the grungy
details
a perspective viewer or exhibit
attendee
to use manipulates inside a cloud-based
embedded notebook and explore what the
artifact is all about
and then
moving on from that we can provide very
detailed computational explanations
starting with the artifact itself and
then using the power of the wolfram
language to pull out the information
that it contains interpret what it means
and discuss it in terms of
mathematics involved and larger
mathematical context
so just say a few more quick words about
learning journeys which you'll see
shortly
these were intended as sort of an
engaging and fun way to journey through
these artifacts
they're aimed at students and other
virtual museum visitors who are
interested in the mathematical story
perhaps more so than the mathematical
content itself so their primary visual
with lots of description and minimal
mathematics they could be useful for
classroom exploration or as a teaching
tool
lots of images and links to the detailed
artificial artifact write-ups
also include interactive contents
the two that we'll be viewing shortly
show your work mathematical beans and
knotted strings and we're working on
more
so now just very briefly a word about
how this these pages that you're about
to see are built so they're built
entirely using the wolfram language
this has a lot of benefits for us a
particular one
for example is that we can use
mathematica notebooks as a way to take
all the data that we want to turn into a
web page and collect it all nicely in
just normal mathematica structures
so here you can see we have a collection
of sections with
appropriate names and content inside may
contain markup maybe links
in this case we have a section that is
for interactive content and you can see
it's really just a manipulate cell
reverse closed
and using the nice features of
mathematica this can be exported
directly via cloud embedding
without the need to do anything else no
custom html programming no nothing
similarly for computational explanation
we can write up
uh in plain words and in code and using
mathematica entities
uh long detailed explanation again
possibly with hyperlinks or what have
you
and this again can be just included
as is more or less
uh into the cloud
and then at the okay and then here we
have all our metadata again as links or
entities where appropriate
we have our main image we have uh
additional images also that will be on
the website
dates more metadata nicely mathematica
generated maps using our geo
functionality
and
here links to other resources and
bibliographic sources
okay so i just want to emphasize um oh i
should also say all the content is built
and hosted in the wolfram cloud so the
fact that the wolfram cloud continues to
be actively developed and is already as
strong as it is
has really let this project go forward
in a very quick and convenient way
and i just wanted to say that while
there are a lot of bells and whistles
behind the scene the core to actually
creating the artifact pages is really
this bit of code here we have an html
template with appropriate variable slots
that we take
we populate from our source notebooks
we
apply xml template to it we export it as
a form and we deploy it as the cloud on
a desired url with public permissions
and that's basically ninety percent of
it so that has proved convenient
extremely convenient
the other benefits of using the wolfram
language are the ones we know
we can
keep everything in one very convenient
place
we can build whatever we need to so just
given
a mathematica entity
with geo information we can write code
to produce maps timelines whatever we
want and we can incrementally build
simply by changing
checking for changed content in the
notebook
all right so let's get to the fun part
now
okay
there we go so this is what the front
page of the history of mathematics
project website looks like
you can see here are nine exhibit pages
and down here are our two existing and
more coming soon learning journeys
and
let's begin by exploring some of these
so uh we looked earlier at
the pottery shard so let's click here
into the polyhedron
exhibit you can see a couple things
we have a nice
um we have a nice uh navigation section
where you can pop up and see
um all the different
exhibit areas as well as the learning
journeys
we have a short description of what's
what this exhibit actually entails
and we have a set of
actual artifacts inside this exhibit
with a nice rollover that shows you
details about them
and we have a clickable timeline
again that just provides you information
about these artifacts in a slightly
different way
so
let's go to click on pottery shard
icosahedron construction
and
here you can see what a build page looks
like
it has the main image a little bit of a
general description
it has
a more detailed description such as when
things were discovered who found them
uh it has a bunch of thumbnails which by
clicking on
we can get a convenient
carousel view at larger resolution to
look through these some are taken from
journal articles some are alternate
views or perhaps annotated views of the
original artifact
here you can see much of the metadata
collected and you can see here's a the
nice maps that we generated using
geofunctionality and mathematica
furthermore if you look at most of these
you can see this and my guess by this
nice little spikey
that we actually have a link and where
this link is is to compute it involved
from alpha so if i didn't know that
there's an elephant team in egypt i can
just click on it
it will pop up
in wolfram alpha and give me whatever
information
the wolfram knowledge base has about
this island so that's a nice way to sort
of make these instead of sort of just
dead information things that you can go
and explore more about
again
each artifact has a timeline so i could
click on one of these and it would show
the artifact information here's the
interactive content this should look
fairly familiar
in fact this is exactly what was in the
notebook and it shows
step by step
what the construction is
from proposition 16 of euclid's elements
that was
as portrayed in this artifact
so now we go down below again this
should look familiar this is what it
what's in the notebook just
automatically exported and embedded via
the notebook and better this is to the
extent
possible automatically interactive via
the nice cloud functionality
manipulates also work here as you've
just seen you can do 3d rotations and
after a little while the whole thing
will snap back
and then
here are other resources additional
reading etc
including links to other artifacts that
are related to this one
so that's the first artifact i wanted to
go through
let's go through a different one let's
go through one in geometry
so here
let's go to the moscow mathematical
papyrus which is perhaps one of the more
famous ones
one more famous ancient mathematical
text from egypt
you can see this uh obviously
geometrical figure in it again we have
descriptions
um metadata timeline
and as you can see here here's one of
the nice
interactives that is uh
showing
basically a version of this figure that
you see here note this little squiggle
here which is hierarchic
turns out for the number
well we wait number six
so you can play around with using the
formula for this particular geometric
solid
that apparently was known to the
egyptians to see how uh the various
values would change
as you change them using the slider
and there's a much more detailed
computational explanation in this case
the papyrus contains
25 mathematical problems
some of them are more interesting or
less interesting than others for example
they're ones on
ship parts
they're ones on brewing beer i guess
that's fairly interesting
the ones that are perhaps most famous
are the ones related to geometry so
problem 10 concerns the calculation of a
hemisphere
stated is a basket so a hemispherical
basket with a given mouth whereby mouth
is meant diameter
so given a hemisphere with this diameter
what is its surface area
so at the end of this description and
procedure that is described into papyrus
it says you multiply four and a half by
seven and one-ninth and you get 32 which
indeed is the case
so we can explore this a little more
using the
formula
2 pi r squared for the
surface area of a hemisphere
and leaving pi as a variable and solving
for it you can see that this is true
using an approximation for pi
is 256 over 81
which is in fact pretty darn close to pi
i'm not sure i cannot recall now if it's
quite known how the egyptians arrived at
that but it's a very good approximation
and it gives you
very for practical purposes a
very good approximation to the area of
your basket
the one that is actually featured in the
main image is again the volume of a
square pyramidal frustum
and again here you see that little
squiggle there that corresponds to the
height six
in hierarchic
we can in mathematica directly compute
the volume of a frustum what do you know
it's 56
that's exactly what
the egyptians said it was so good for
them or we can compute it using uh the
well-known volume formula and again we
get 56.
so to my knowledge it's not known how it
is that the egyptians figured out this
formula but clearly they knew about it
and they knew how to use it so that's
pretty interesting stuff
so the final
artifact that i wanted to show is this
very interesting one
called a yupana
that was used in the andean region of
south america by the incas
and yupe in the indigenous indigenous
andean
quechua language means to count
so these there's a wide variety of these
this partic one of this particular shape
was described around 1615 but they were
clearly used before and after that and
you can see a bunch of little dots on
them that represent individual numbers
so again we have some images a very
interesting one i'll talk about a little
bit
let's get down to the so the interesting
thing about the upana
is that it was a way not to record but
to compute
so for instance if you put a bean
on one of these rows corresponding to
tens ones hundreds
then you represent
the total number of dots covered by one
or more beans so for instance five you
cover the five ones that gives you five
six you cover a couple of them what not
and the interesting thing is if we vary
the number of red and green beans
that by applying a set of rearrangement
rules that don't depend on the order
don't involve carries or anything like
that you can actually arrive at
the solution to this addition problem
and if you wanted you can include
different numbers of beans they don't
have to be different colors and you can
just solve this thing
um
in in this way
so there's a detailed computation
computational explanation of how this
works interestingly some of you may have
noticed the number of dots actually
corresponds to the first fibonacci
numbers which in some sense makes this a
very efficient ray uh to represent
numbers using a small number of
dot configurations
and then uh i mentioned there's a way to
rearrange these so
here's the set of moves you could take
two beans on one and move it to two you
could take two beans on two and move one
to one and so on
and doing this basically you can perform
a computation from a beginning state to
an ending state that seems almost more
game-like than uh wrote teaching and
learning your addition facts so this is
in fact used in some south american
beginning education programs to teach
children how to add and if you're
curious there is actually a kit that you
can purchase for yourself
i don't think it includes the lima beans
but it includes some other
fun looking counters
okay so those were the and just and as i
said there's a large number of these so
you can feel free to go there and
explore yourself
now i wanted to just briefly touch on
the learning journeys which are another
very interesting
aspect and way to look at these
and again these learning journeys the
two you can get to from any place on the
website through this browse exhibit
so the first one is show your work
and this basically emphasizes that
through the ages it's not just um
you and your kids who are having to do
homework people have been doing homework
for thousands of years and in babylonia
students did their math homework on clay
tablets when they were practicing to be
scribes
so it shows you know a number of
pictures of tablets
this one is interesting because it
actually gives you an idea you might
think this tablet is some big huge thing
that you have to you know lug around in
a wheeled cart but it turns out this
particular one is about the size of a
credit card so that gives it some
interesting
applicability and sort of hands-on feel
all of these are linked so if you want
to go to the full
artifact you can very easily do that
let's go back now
and uh one point that is emphasized we
try to emphasize the sort of fun and
interesting aspects is
this particular multiplication tablet
though again we have a detailed write-up
of contains errors but it contains not
only student errors when doing their the
multiplication but in fact teacher
errors as well as highlighted here and
if you go and explore that particular
artifact it will show in detail what
those were and how the mistakes were
made
so
student errors have been around for
thousands of years and apparently
teacher errors too
you can there are some interactives
built into these and then many many more
links to the individual artifacts
okay i'm just going to show the last
learning journeys and then i see a
number of you have things that you'd
like to
ask about or discuss so we'll go on to
those
but first let's talk about our second
learning journey which is called
mathematical beans and knotted strings
which
i hope is an intriguing title
and this refers to
artifacts made by the mochi people who
are people who lived in northern peru
between about 200 and 900 ce so they
lived near the ocean and they made some
beautiful artifacts
involving
octopuses
you can see here there's a gold
decoration
here's a headband involving eight armed
objects
and they like to build
stirrup spout bottles also decorated
with octopuses
so i guess there's a little math there
eight octopus where the real math comes
in is with the beans as you've already
seen with the yupana it turns out beans
had a very important part in the mochi
culture they were not only something you
could eat and count with they were in
some ways also a status symbol so
there's more descriptive detail
of that in some of these write-ups you
can see they decorated
some of their stirrup bottles with beans
those are all lima beans
there's not a it's not a coincidence
that lima or lima peru
sounds very similar to lima bean
so they use them for counting they also
had
beautiful geometric
art in their weavings and in their
pottery some of you might say that looks
suspiciously like
cellular automata many years before it
became popular in the vogue
some of their weaving is very beautiful
so there's geometric patterns here and
this and you can see there's also a
little nested dotted circles in the top
which has um
special significance we have an entire
artifact
right up uh devoted to explaining this
in detail where you can actually create
your own balance scale by varying
different things
seeing how to nest the circles and so on
um so there's just a lot of interesting
visual detail that is also connected uh
with the history and the math
again some interactives
this is very similar to the um you know
adding the beans using a yupana that we
just saw
and
this particular yupon is very
interesting because it was recently
found and is two meters across
so it basically filled a road and i
guess the idea is you could have
multiple people working in parallel
moving beans or whatever they used on
this large one around
to uh to do a parallel computation of
your addition with lots of other links
down below
so
uh that concludes the show and tell
portion
and i would just like to take the
opportunity to uh thank you for your
attention and patience with my not
sharing the screen when zoom was telling
me that i was but to also thank the
people on this final slide
because there are many other people
who've been involved in
all the work and
all the research that were involved in
making this happen
so thanks once again let me see if i can
figure out how to get to
my chat so i can take any questions that
people have give me one second here
i work on my other screen
okay schedule my agenda
and
okay chat
okay are there any questions if so
please feel free to write them in the
chat
i'm not seeing any questions
okay
so i see
somebody raised her hand
okay so i have a question how did you
generate these pages
well as i mentioned
i basically have a build system that
took a set of notebooks
uh including computational content and
then used
something called the wolfram
notebook embedder
to include the relevant pieces
um directly in the cloud so if we go
back to let me open up
one of these pages
oops didn't mean to do that one
okay so hopefully people can see this
and let's pick one of these let's pick
one of these
and let's look at the page source
if i can find the right
there we go
okay so you can see
this is just simple html there is a
notebook embedded call here right here
that is a simple one line in the html
that basically
automatically includes
all that interactive content that you
say
and it's not quite as snappy that you
saw it's not quite as snappy as it would
be in a real notebook but it's for the
most part unless you're doing
very complicated 3d graphics with
opacity say it's pretty snappy
so for our purposes it works pretty well
okay
so i see a question from bruce do we
have an exhibit on emmy nether
we do not yet um
so we tried to be as inclusive
with regard to
culture location gender everything else
we could um nether emmy nether is
definitely a person who came up and we'd
love to include some of her works
however we've only been working on this
for a year
so we had to sort of uh just pick a
subset
and work with those she's definitely on
our list we did however feature this uh
nice
figure from the famous textbook by maria
agnesi
from which the witch of agnesi uh
comes forth
so there's certainly much more that can
be added but for a year's worth of work
we're pretty proud of how much we've
accomplished we really look forward to
getting more feedback on this
and if resources allow continuing to
expand and extend it
okay i see a question do we think that
ancient civilizations made a kind of
programming language
you know who the right person to ask
that question would be that is probably
a stephen wolfram question
in the
artifacts that we have studied so far
i would say we've seen many interesting
things including mazes including things
that look kind of like algorithms
but uh in terms of being a language i at
least am not familiar uh of any of
anything uh that would fall into that
category but it's a very interesting
question and i bet stephen would have
many things to say about it were he here
and he could join us
uh let's see
any other questions
we are certainly um interested in your
feedback
um so the learning journeys is one that
we're hoping uh it might be of
particular interest and use to students
and teachers during this pandemic and as
a way to sort of get into
the more detailed
mathematics
since of course we're we use the wolfram
language we use mathematica that's our
favorite part
but this is pretty cool too so if this
in some small way can get
students and teachers interested
and
interested in exploring not just the
artifacts
uh not just recognize and appreciate
that they have mathematics on them but
sort of understand a little bit of how
that mathematics works how it fits in
culturally you can learn history you can
learn geography you can learn
mathematics all at the same time
so uh the study of math through
mathematical artifacts really has
i think a lot of nice uh ways
to get people interested hopefully keep
their attention and then lead them on to
the more mathy side of things
so um i think that is technically the
end of our discussion i have a question
will i be posting files for this
presentation
yes i can go ahead and post the notebook
as you saw the notebook itself is
primarily just a summary
the the main work and the interesting
stuff is on the website itself
so
i will go ahead and sign off here
and go ahead and post that notebook to
the um the talk
uh sorry again for the technical
glitches at the beginning but i hope it
has been uh of interest to you
nonetheless
uh thank you once again for coming uh
both to this talk and to our first ever
virtual
wolfram technology conference and i look
forward to interacting with all of you
more in the future and hopefully in
person sometime soon
thanks very much
have a great rest your day bye
you